are you going to win next year I think
we have a very good chance the economy
is not good I'll make it good everyone
knows you know everyone knows that even
Democrats they say well we agree that
Putin would have never gone in he
wouldn't I don't you're not going in
Putin would have never gone into Ukraine
president XI of China would never even
be talking about Taiwan we had that
conversation strongly I stopped North
Korea from doing some really bad things
and my relationship with Kim Jong-un is
very good who knows what's going to
happen there there is an observation
that is often done when someone is
evaluated psychiatrically about whether
they have this sort of like tangential
thinking
and Trump has it to an incredible degree
where he simply asked are you going to
win next year and he talks about his
relationship with Kim Jong-un and it's
really I mean you call it a feature or a
bug of Trump's speech but it is there
very strongly